[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen Folge ich bin Toni Heyer
und ich bin Mirco Kasimir wir sind heute
am Starnberger See und erzählen euch
eine Geschichte die voller Glück und
Hoffnung beginnt mit viel Musik Kultur
und Fröhlichkeit aber sie nimmt kein
gutes Ende denn zum Schluss herrschen
die Wut und Verzweiflung eines Mannes
der um seine Freiheit bangt am Ende
steht ein zweifacher tot der auch mehr
als 130 Jahre danach für Rätselraten
sorgt der und es ist natürlich kein
Zufall dass wir hier mit Musik von
Richard Wagner angefangen haben
[Musik]
denn unsere tödliche Geschichte die
spielt in Bayern und hat mit ihm zu tun
ihr bekommt jetzt also ein bisschen
Allgemeinbildung und später klären wir
auch ganz nebenbei wer die Post in
Europa erfunden hat aber von vorn Mirko
leg los am 25 August 1845 nachts um 1
Uhr wird im Schloss Nymphenburg bei
München otto-friedrich Wilhelm Ludwig
von Wittelsbach geboren sein Großvater
besteht darauf dass das Kind Ludwig
gerufen wird wie er selbst die Eltern
des kleinen Ludwig sind Kronprinz
Maximilian von Bayern und Kronprinzessin
Marie gleich nach der Geburt wird das
Baby zum Stillen eine arme aus dem Dorf
Miesbach übergeben aber im Jahr darauf
stirbt die Arme Ludwig wird von einem
auf den anderen Tag abgestellt er
verliert drastisch an Gewicht und
bekommt schließlich einen schlimmen
Fieber Infekt
zwischendurch sieht es richtig richtig
schlecht aus aber das Kind berappelt
sich Ludwig wird jetzt der Erzieherin
Sibylle mile-haus übergeben die sich bis
zu seinem siebten Geburtstag um ihn
kümmert
1848 wird Ludwigs Bruder Otto geboren
die Jungs verbringen ihre Kindheit und
Jugend vor allem auf Schloss
Hohenschwangau 100 km südwestlich von
München in den Räumen hängen viele
Gemälde und Wandteppiche mit Motiven aus
der Sagenwelt des Mittelalters die
Mutter geht mit den Brüdern gern
Bergsteigen und Wandern ansonsten werden
sie von verschiedenen hoflehrern und
Offizieren streng erzogen nachdem
Ludwigs Opa abdankt wird sein Vater Max
König von Bayern die Aufteilung ist auf
ungute Weise typisch für die Zeit der
Vater ist abweisend und kühl zu den
Jungs die Mutter kümmert sich liebevoll
wenn die Eltern auf Reisen sind schreibt
sie Briefe und bringt bei der Rückkehr
natürlich Spielzeug mit
der Opa weckt Ludwigs Begeisterung für
Literatur und Baukunst mit Vater Max
verbindet Ludwig kaum etwas wenn die
beiden ganz selten mal spazieren gehen
wissen sie nicht was sie sich erzählen
sollen später schreibt Ludwig sein Vater
habe ihn von oben herab und sehe kalt
behandelt ihre Sommerferien verbringen
die Prinzen oft in der Villa der
Königsfamilie in Berchtesgaden dort
entsteht eine Freundschaft mit dem
Fürstensohn Paul von Ton und Taxis hier
kommt jetzt ein bisschen
Allgemeinbildung dazu die Familie tun
und Taxis erfand in Europa quasi das
postwiesen deswegen an mit Reitern die
im 14 Jahrhundert als Kuriere unterwegs
waren und führte schließlich um 1600
herum zur Gründung der kaiserlichen
Reichspost
bekannte Nachfahren der Familie sind die
bekannte Gräfin Gloria von Thurn und
Taxis und ihr Bruder Alexander von
Schönburg der ist übrigens unser Bild
adelsexperte aber Klammer zu und weiter
in der Geschichte
am 10 märz 1864 stirbt Ludwigs Vater
Maximilian nach einer kurzen heftigen
Krankheit an der sogenannten
rotlauferkrankung das ist eine
bakterielle Hautentzündung mit gerade
mal 18 Jahren wird Ludwig jetzt König
von Bayern genauer gesagt
Ludwig II von Gottes Gnaden König von
Bayern falls Graf bei Reihen Herzog von
Bayern Franken und in Schwaben
bei den Trauerfeiern für Maximilian am
14 März sieht man den jungen Mann zum
ersten Mal in seiner Rolle als König in
der Öffentlichkeit Ludwig ist mit seiner
Größe von 193 quasi ein Riese erst recht
für die damalige Zeit er hat volle
gewellte Haare einen ernsten Blick aus
dunklen Augen und volle Lippen als er
sein Amt antritt weiß er wahrscheinlich
nicht in was für eine spannende Phase
die Welt jetzt Eintritt europa steht vor
dem Staat in die Moderne
enorme technische Fortschritte
revolutionieren die Landwirtschaft und
führen schließlich zur Schaffung der
Industrie die Städte wachsen politisch
wird Europa vom Zarenreich Russland von
den Engländern Spanien und vom großen
Österreich Ungarn beherrscht und vom
mächtigen Frankreich oder Napoleon dem
dritten
Deutschland gibt es streng genommen zu
dieser Zeit noch nicht Preußen ist das
mächtigste Reich auf deutschem Boden und
dann gibt es noch Königreiche wie
Sachsen wird im Berg und eben Bayern
Ludwig muss als bayerischer König sehr
schwieriger Entscheidungen treffen schon
zwei Jahre nach seinem Amtsantritt
während Bayern im Krieg zwischen Preußen
und Österreich zwischen die Fronten
Preußen will ein deutsches Großreich
unter seiner Führung am liebsten würde
Ludwig aber sein Bayern aus diesem Krieg
raushalten
aber es gibt halt ein Bündnisvertrag mit
den Ösis
Preußen gewinnt die Auseinandersetzung
und Bayern muss Millionen nach Berlin
überweisen gönnen wir uns bis zum
nächsten Krieg ein bisschen Kultur denn
die ist im bayerischen König sehr
wichtig Ludwig bewundert den Komponisten
Richard Wagner den 32 Jahre älteren
Künstler trifft er im mai 1864 zum
ersten Mal persönlich und sofort fühlen
sich die Männer verbunden Ludwig lässt
Wagner in einer Residenz in München
wohnen und fördert ihn finanziell sehr
großzügig damit der ungestört Werke wie
den Ring der Nibelungen schreiben kann
einzig der Umgang mit Juden trennt die
Männer denn Wagner gilt als Antisemit
Ludwig lehnt diese Haltung strikt ab das
zeigt sich z.B bei der Uraufführung des
passivsfall Wagner besteht darauf dass
der Dirigent Levi vor der Premiere zum
Christentum konvertieren soll Ludwig
wischt das vom Tisch Ludwig sorgt
übrigens auch dafür dass die jüdische
Gemeinde zu München ein Grundstück für
ihre eigene Synagoge bekommt Ludwig muss
bei der Freundschaft mit Wagner einiges
einstecken der Komponist braucht ständig
Geld mischt sich in die Politik ein und
er geht später auch noch öffentlich
fremd und zeugt eine uneheliche Tochter
irgendwann kann der König seinen Kumpel
nicht mehr halten Wagner wird von der
bayerischen Staatsregierung aus Bayern
rausgeworfen
bekanntlich bekam der später trotzdem
noch sein Festspielhaus in Bayreuth den
Betrieb dort bekam der König aber schon
nicht mehr richtig mit aber zu diesen
Gründen kommen wir noch erstmal müssen
wir noch von einem weiteren Krieg
berichten und vom Liebesleben des Königs
den Krieg den überlasse ich dir lieber
Mirko und ich stelle euch mal eben
Sophie Charlotte von Bayern vor sie ist
zwei Jahre jünger als Ludwig und kommt
aus einer Nebenlinie der witelsbacher
ist also eigentlich eine Verwandte des
Königs
die beiden kennen sich schon seit sie
Kinder sind aber 1867 da ist es
plötzlich Liebe Ludwig ruft eine
Verlobung aus
über die Liebe
am Hofe ist man überrascht denn bis
dahin hatte Ludwig allen erzählt er
werde niemals heiraten woher der
Sinneswandel Zeitgenossen vermuten das
Ludwig sein Leben in diesen Tagen
radikal ändern wollte weil seine
Freundschaft mit seinem Adjutanten Paul
von Thurn und Taxis zerbrochen war dem
Freund aus Kindertagen also sagen wir es
hier mal ganz einfach nach allem was man
weiß ist König Ludwig II von Bayern
schwul und Paul von Turnen und Taxis das
war sein erster Partner die 1867
ausgerufene Verlobung mit Sophie
Charlotte die entwickelt sich zur fast
den verlobungsball im Februar verlässt
Ludwig schon nach einer Stunde wieder
während wir die geplante Hochzeit noch
reichlich Geld ausgegeben wird
entfremdet sich das Paar immer weiter im
oktober 1867 wird die Verlobung dann
auch schon wieder aufgelöst übrigens in
Wahrheit hat sich Sophie drei Tage nach
der Verlobung einen Kaufmann namens
Edgar hanfstengel verliebt von da an
trafen die beiden sich heimlich auf
Dauer aber war eine Beziehung mit einem
bürgerlichen und denkbar und so
heiratete Sophie Charlotte später den
Adligen Franzosen Ferdinand der Allan
drei Jahre nach dem verlobungs-chaos
muss Ludwig wieder überleben und Tod
entscheiden Preußen zieht gegen
Frankreich in den Krieg und Bayern hat
sich vier Jahre zuvor dem sogenannten
Schutz und Schutzbündnis mit Berlin
angeschlossen Ludwigs Untertan haben um
es mal ehrlich zu formulieren überhaupt
gar keinen Bock auf Krieg und schon gar
nicht auf den Norddeutschen Bund den
Preußen die Bayern unbedingt ein
Gemeinden will immerhin endet der Krieg
gegen die Franzosen mit einem deutschen
Sieg auch dank eines bayerischen
Vorstoßes bei Landau Kummer hat Ludwig
in dieser Zeit übrigens trotzdem sein
jüngerer Bruder Otto der im Umgang mit
Menschen schon lange als Schwierigkeit
der stützt psychisch rapide ab er wird
unter ärztlicher Aufsicht gestellt und
gilt ab 1872 offiziell als geisteskrank
auf den Sieg im Deutsch-Französischen
Krieg Folgen lange komplizierte
politische Verhandlungen und weil wir
hier keinen history Podcast sind fassen
wir das mal kurz zusammen Bayern wurde
jetzt doch Teil eines Deutschen Reiches
unter preußischer Führung dafür überwies
Berlin eine Menge Geld ein Ludwigs
Bayern und ihn persönlich aber zu dieser
Zeit stimmt mit dem Kini schon irgendwas
nicht mehr
der Kini also bayerisch für König zieht
sich nach und nach aus der
Öffentlichkeit zurück er steigert sich
in fantastische Baupläne hinein die
unfassbar viel Geld kosten schon seit
1869 wird für ihnen Füssen direkt in der
Nähe des Schlosses Hohenschwangau das
Schloss Neuschwanstein neu errichtet
bald darauf lässt er am festsaalbau der
Münchner Residenz einen riesigen
Wintergarten bauen und Ludwig plant
einen Palast Neubau mit Stilelementen
aus China und dem alten bizanz der
schiebte auch Pionierleistungen an wie
die Elektrifizierung des Münchner
Residenztheaters aber der Kini driftet
ab am Hof und in der Staatsregierung
munkelt man nicht nur über all die
wahnsinnig hohen Ausgaben angeblich
beordert der schwule König auch Soldaten
zu sich und zwingt sie zum Sex fest
steht eine Gruppe aus Staatsführung
Militär und Adel will den König
loswerden und tatsächlich verfällt der
ie vor den Augen seines Hofstaates er
macht die Nacht zum Tag säuft und
futtert süßes ohne Ende er wird Fett die
Zähne fallen nach und nach außen was
genau mit ihm passiert das ist nicht
ganz klar weil ja keiner mehr fragen
kann
Zeitgenossen erklären Ludwig schlicht
für verrückt für Seelen gestört oder
paranoid moderne Psychiater deuten seine
Symptome heute als Zeichen von
Sozialphobie also Scheu vor anderen
Menschen und als schizo typische Störung
in der Fachliteratur heißt es Menschen
mit einer schizo-typischen
Persönlichkeitsstörung haben ein
tiefgreifendes Defizit bei den
zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen und
ihren sozialen Fähigkeiten außerdem
zeigen sie Eigentümlichkeiten in ihrem
Verhalten im Denken und bei der
Wahrnehmung so ist Ihr äußeres
Erscheinungsbild oft skurril oder
ungepflegt und ihre Sprache eigenwillig
auf andere wirken sie oft unzugänglich
gefühlsarm und gleichgültig es ist
schließlich der bayerische
Ministerpräsident Johann von Lutz der im
Frühling 1886 ein Gutachten über den
König in Auftrag gibt und zwar beim
obermedizinalrat dr Bernhard von guten
der ist Spezialist für gehirnanatomie
oder wie man damals auch sagte Irrenarzt
seine Majestät sind in sehr weit
fortgeschrittenem grade sehen gestört
Allerhöchst dieselben leiden an jener
Form von Geisteskrankheit die mit dem
Namen ein paar neuer bezeichnet wird in
der Nacht auf den 10 Juni erscheint eine
Gruppe von elf offiziellen auf Schloss
Neuschwanstein um den König abzusetzen
aber der ist vorgewarnt versperrt das
Tor und Ludwigs Treue Anhängerin Baronin
spera von truchses erscheint für eine
Furie vor der Kommission und bedroht sie
mit ihrem Schiff und was für ein Debakel
das ganze Ludwig erwägt derweil sogar
den Selbstmord aber schließlich gibt er
nach und lässt sich in sein kleines
Schloss im Berg am Starnberger See
bringen
das hatte man zu einer Art privat
Sanatorium umgebaut um den König kümmern
sich jetzt der Arzt Dr von guden und
Wachleute
Nachfolger Ludwigs wird sein Onkel
Luitpold am Abend des 13 juni 1886
brechen der König und sein Arzt von
Kunden zu einem Spaziergang am
Starnberger See auf der damals übrigens
noch sehr heißt als sie um 18:45 Uhr
losgehen kommt ausnahmsweise kein
Wachpersonal mit es beginnt zu regnen
zunächst leise dann immer stärker gegen
20 Uhr wundert sich das Personal im
Schloss wo die beiden überhaupt bleiben
königliche Wachleute strömen aus und
durchsuchen den Park finden aber nichts
mit einem Fischerkahn wird das Seeufer
abgesucht um 23 Uhr wird der König
entdeckt leblos auf dem Wasser treibend
eine halbe Stunde später wird auch von
guten entdeckt auch er treibt Tod im
Wasser
Ludwigs Uhr ist um 18:54 Uhr stehen
geblieben die Obduktion ergibt bei ihm
keine Verletzungen von guten Gesicht ist
von Kratzwunden und einem blauen Fleck
entstellt die Uhr des Arztes ist
ebenfalls durch eindringendes Wasser zum
Stehen gekommen aber erst um 20:10 Uhr
was ist also passiert
die offizielle Version geht so
Ludwig schlägt den Spaziergang vor weil
er Selbstmord begehen möchte als er
damit am Ufer beginnt will ihn von guten
daran hindern es kommt zum Handgemenge
Ludwig drückt den Arzt unter Wasser bis
der sich nicht mehr bewegt und dann
erleidet er also der König im zwölf Grad
kalten Wasser einen Herzinfarkt aber
warum tickte von gutens Uhr noch mehr
als anderthalb Stunden weiter ja
kursieren bald natürlich
Verschwörungstheorien hatten der Preuße
Bismarck und der bayerische
Ministerpräsident Lutz ihre Finger als
Auftraggeber mit im Spiel oder war von
guten ihr Auftragsmörder
immerhin hat er ausgerechnet bei diesem
Spaziergang auf Wachen verzichtet etwa
weil er keine Zeugen wollte königstreue
Bayern glauben bis heute sogar das
Ludwig hinterrücks erschossen wurde das
Gewehr wurde anschließend fortgeschafft
dann hätte von guten vielleicht als
Zeuge dran glauben müssen völlig egal
wie es war fest steht nur Ludwig wird am
19 juni 1886 nach einem Leichen Zug
durch München in der Gruft der
Michaelskirche beigesetzt sein Herz
wurde getrennt bestattet und am 16
august 1886 in die Gnadenkapelle von
Altötting übertragen bis heute ist das
Rätsel um den Tod des bayerischen König
Ludwig nicht gelöst die Mythen und
Verschwörungstheorien halten sich auch
heute noch hartnäckig was sicherlich zur
Faszination an diesem Fall beiträgt
und damit sind wir am Ende des heutigen
falls angekommen vielen Dank dass ihr
mit dabei wart vielen Dank fürs Zuhören
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid euer
Mirko und eure Toni
für diesen Fall gab es wirklich zahllose
Quellen unter anderem die Webseite des
Schlosses Neuschwanstein sowie Artikel
der Süddeutschen Zeitung und das
Bayerischen Rundfunks Skript Stefan
netzemann Postproduktion durch die
wakewitz Studios München